you
hi my name is Lloyd Lamar and I've been
facing the bay area for about three
years now as you can tell i'm french and
i'm an entrepreneur i have i cannot fix
my accent so i gave up fixing it and i
am thrilled to be here so thank you for
inviting me and i have created a few
setups in europe and currently i'm doing
two things probably like five startups
one is seesmic which takes all my time
and it's about bringing all the social
software thats Cabo has talked about
together because it's a real pain to go
and check all those places and share in
all those places so we're solving this
very specific problem and we are on six
platform so if you have an Android phone
you can try if you have a blog where you
can try iphone next weekend so web
everywhere and the other thing I'm doing
is the conference called the web in
Paris which covers two and a half
thousand people from 50 countries lots
of students too and it became the
largest tech event in Europe one of the
top in the world and we did it with zero
marketing absolutely zero marketing all
with social software i started with 200
people now we have two and a half
thousand and every year i get people
complain that i have not invited them
because we don't invite anyone we don't
have any sales person calling we don't
have any marketing material zero and it
does like 1.5 million dollars in revenue
every year little business barely breaks
even though so this is what you know
I've been offered to talk about today's
the how the marketing is changing we've
social software and who in the room
would like to launch his business in the
future that's all half of a room on
lingua come on you can do it
you know it's ours at Ted last week and
James Cameron tucked avatar right and
James said you have the right to fail
but you never have the right to fear
something flows like that I'll come back
you do you know shouldn't be scared of
failure you can fail but don't fear
anything just try so anyway I'm going to
concentrate on this this is my blog and
I've written this post yesterday which
is how I think marketing is changing and
the rules that either startups or
anything you do should should follow to
some extent and even large businesses
route 22 of them and I have 15 minutes
so I have to go really fast this is why
I wrote it if you want to find it again
but the first thing and I'm going to
adapt it to entrepreneurship because i'm
sure you're interested in that i think
the first thing you have to do is not a
market research if you want to start a
business is really to identify an empty
space which you think is interesting and
just focus on that some some some place
where not that many people have created
so for example in location these days
there is a lot happening like you know
foursquare and gowalla and Google
Latitude like saying where you are is
something very new Twitter still even
voice two and a half years old a
fantastic ecosystem which has a lot of
empty space by empty space as I mean a
lot of places where you can create so
focus on that final a niche make it as
small as possible so that you can be as
good as possible in that niche if you
make it too wide it's going to be very
risky because you difficult to be really
good so it try to be really really good
at something very very very small
probably the best in the wall that step
good in would would say try to be that
and then listen so first rule is listen
just so easy today you use twitter
search you use Google Blog search you
use now Google as this real-time search
and you just follow this space and see
what people are doing and what people
are saying about it if your brand is not
quoted on Twitter this day is it's
either dead or it doesn't exist yet
where a driver have people criticized
heavily our brand then not talk about it
at all because it's what of math and
again these conferences like that I take
as an example very often the web went
from 200 people like a bunch of friends
gathering six years ago into two and a
half thousand people just from what of
mouth so you'd rather have word of mouth
even negative we had a big crisis at the
web when I invited politicians I had to
president the same day Shimon Peres and
the french President Nicolas Sarkozy
speak and that created a whole you know
controversy because bloggers didn't want
to meet the politicians that much and
the way I did it by imposing it not
telling people before and so on created
a huge mess I had like the worst week of
my life only criticism you're burned
you're never gonna you know be able to
gather those people again it's awful
what you did to us and it actually
turned into a real huge positive for the
conference because I answered actually
this Kabul advise me a lot on that every
single piece of criticism I listed them
all I listened and answered every single
of em and then I I said what I would do
with it so for probably not to impose
politicians anymore to an audience that
was not prepared to that that was a good
lesson you could have told me that
before I'm sure right not to do that
answer as I was saying answer answer
answer it looks very easy to say it but
it's not that easy to answer many brands
listen but they don't engage very few
brands as Robert said Scott Monte at
Ford or you know various various bell
for example reach out that Dell on
twitter you can follow those brands are
answering all day long and as I said
focus on the negative and start by this
first it's a mark of attention if people
criticize you or your brand sometimes
insult you very often right it's it's
awful what you read
that's okay it's attention it means they
care so you no answer and gauge with
them of course you have to find the
limit if it's a troll maybe you don't
want to engage that much but and thank
people if they say your brand rocks if
it's cool just thank them engage 24
hours a day I'm sorry this isn't maybe I
should have done slide after all anyway
you have a blog post engage 24 hours a
day we the way we did it is we have two
full-time community evangelist in San
Francisco and one in Europe so that we
can be 24 hours a day and you could tell
how but that like we can't afford that
if you think about it this is the budget
of a PR agency a monthly cost of a PR
agency you scratch that i'm going to
make new friends again today and cancel
that put it in full time community
evangelist who will listen an answer all
day long my goal is that anyone who says
this week on twitter we answer even if
it's oh that's great we just you know we
answer that's what i want to do is very
tough to do 24 hours a day I guarantee
if you do this you're going to have so
much love and interaction it's about a
small quantity of people engaging with
your brands and not millions every
single user that you make happy by
answering he will tell 10 other friends
that's your brand is cool that's what we
do you work very well for us that's our
only marketing budget is what of math be
as transparent as possible i have to
speed up so don't cheat if your product
sucks you have to recognize that it
sucks if if it's not complete that's
okay people will forgive you for not
being perfect but never forgive you for
cheating for saying no no no we put it
under the carpet like you know the old
style advertising where you used to say
everything is fantastic right this car
has no problems it's the best car in the
world and you never talk about the
negative sometimes actually talking
about the negatives in public as you are
a CEO of that startup or if it's your
project makes it even stronger because
you recognize that it that it's it's a
problem and so when you launch your
starter my advice is lon
as fast as possible you know throw
yourself in water and just start
swimming you will learn and iterate
group the feedback i'm going to show you
how we do it group with feedback on a
site like this which is a here this one
is yours voice so we have so much
feedback we have about a mention of
seismic every minute that we can't read
it all it's very difficult even though
that's what I'd like to do and so what
we do it's kind of a dig like if you
want to see you know our products so for
example on CSP web our web-based version
you have our users enter feature
suggestions and ideas and they they can
put whatever they like and then people
vote on them so you can see for example
we support Twitter very want Facebook
100 people voted on that and we're
building just that right now and so I
call this my public road map public
because anyone can see it including the
competition so you have to you know be
careful of course but see I want to know
what people want on my blackberry
product I have that here all our
products have a transparent feedback
forum like like this and that has been
that has proven very very very useful
for us so gather feedback on a feedback
cycle ike this very very very agile as
you create the products so 11 way we do
it when we launched my company two years
ago here we launched it as I had this
dream that everybody would stop talking
in video and that didn't happen yet it
will trust me i'm sure it will where we
were too early and we didn't have enough
traction so we changed everything into
what our company is doing that you have
to be agile if it doesn't work just
change and move the space and do
something that has more more traction so
change your priorities often based on
this public road map left I've shown you
and keep moving you have to be very very
agile these days don't forget to
innovate squabbles said if a Porsche if
Porsche had listened to its users it
would become a Volvo because you could
have a big trunk and so listening to the
users is not enough you also have to
innovate
obviously create things the empty space
that wasn't created before you have to
create a presence on the most popular
social software all of them you have no
idea maybe you have but i had no idea on
how many interactions i would get
different in LinkedIn van on twitter or
facebook there are not the same people
you think they're ever saying they are
not the same I'm not getting at all the
same level of interaction with linkedin
and the way you do it but where you do
it is two ways either you adapt the
message but it's difficult or you just
publish the same which I decided to do
and actually acquire the little very
cool service called ping FM to just help
you do that share everywhere at the same
time you have to be everywhere you have
to identify your best fans it's not
about getting a million fans like MC
Hammer it's about getting the first I
mean we all we all dream about that
right but it's at the beginning it's
about I'm actually quoting a hammer he
knows that for an hour ago he said that
but you have to start with a hundred
people and 200 very committed fans you
have to focus on those I read verse you
to read set buildings book tribes easy
quartz actually someone else saying a
thousand fans can get the wall out to
millions and you really have to focus on
a small group when you do create focus
on a very small social network that you
could create for them that's what we did
we have these thousand fans on seismic
it's a Ning social network called Team
six week where we gather them all and we
give them exclusives we'd give them
products before anyone else and and I
think they they like it love you you
users I did something very bad to our
office measures to week to week two
weeks ago I said who wants some stickers
and we have like fifty thousand
followers on Twitter and we receive 500
emails in an hour of fans who wanted
stickers of you know with a raccoon
which is there on my computer and of
course we sent every single so she liked
loved it for a week she was just sending
seekers now we found a company doing
that but now we have a sis Mick sticker
on on a snowball
old we have a season you know people
tweet the pictures so it's very good
love around you and I'm almost done you
have to be everywhere and on every
platform and I'm talking about your
brand your company here very tough you
have to be on the web you have to be on
the iphone now to you have to have an
Android app you have to have a nut gap
if you want to reach for 20 million
users that still nokia has especially in
Europe and Asia and not so much in the
u.s. you have to have a blackberry app
so it's a nightmare as a developer it's
horrible because these are all different
cut basis but that's the goal there are
some companies that can help you do that
but if you have a cool brand you should
probably think about being everywhere
and I'm all as well done you need to use
social networking internally if you if
you want to get familiar with it
Salesforce is doing a huge thing with
that you have to participate in all the
cool events that the social networking
junkies like Scoble go to South by
Southwest you know leave the LD maybe
the web TechCrunch 50 and so and go
there and meet meet them even if you're
not a geek bran you have to have real
people in front of us brands because
it's like it's not about fault it's more
about who answers at fault you want to
have a human relationship and few little
things use video very good as Robert
knows of course be proactive and share
as much as you can think about we're
going to have coffee what do we talk
about or have lunch what do we talk
about not don't think about what should
be my next press release because that's
going to be very boring if I you know
have coffee with you and i only talk
about in terms of marketing press really
is going to be super boring i want to
know about you and and companies start
to have a human human voice last point
passions it takes years it doesn't take
days it takes years it doesn't take mon
severs it building trust around
yourselves as brands or around your
company text yours very long process but
then it's extremely useful for doing
good for helping others and if you focus
on helping others even though your
profit oriented business it's probably a
good a good rule so anyway
that was my 22 cents thank you very much